yep you're good to go okay thank you
very much
okay uh as as chair of the house
education committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor and
as a result of coven 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this ba public body is authorized to
meet electronically
this is a subcommittee work session of
the education
committee to address and identify uh
relevant information pertaining to the
new hampshire
uh college and university system as
proposed in
hb2 and that's chapter uh
188-roman one
you'll find that in the um in hb2
in on approximately i don't have the
specific page page 50 i think it is
going further please note that there is
no fiscal location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously
to this meeting however in accordance
with the emergency order
i am confirming that all members of the
subcommittee
have the ability to communicate in
contemporaries contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom
platform or telephone all necessary
access information has been made
available in the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91-8
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271-3600 or email
hcs ledge.state.nh.us
in the event of the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
at this time i'd like to introduce uh
the staff that are supporting us we have
jennifer for who is our committee
researcher
and please uh note that there will be no
votes taken during this
this meeting the subcommittee meeting
we'll start the meeting by
taking a roll call and as i uh
say your names would you please those uh
subcommittee members that are present
would you please state
your that you're present and um
and if anybody else is in the room with
you
as required by the right to know law
okay so going down the agenda obviously
rick ladd is here
uh i'm speaking as right now uh
uh also uh is mike
moffitt here he hasn't checked in yet
right
now i haven't seen i've seen him either
okay uh oliver ford representative ford
president in my office in chester alone
thank you very much
uh representative nell miler uh mel
miler calling in from contook new
hampshire and i'm here in my office
alone
thank you representative dave luno erin
hopkinson
with ozzie with ozzie great there you go
okay and and representative ellison
uh i'm president i'm here alone in my
home in concord
okay that makes up the committee
membership there are six people on this
committee
and today working with us we have dr ed
mckay
past president of the university system
new hampshire
and has been a a strong advocate for
education here in the state
and as i alluded to at the beginning we
are here today
and on a very short time frame to
consider and identify
relevant information uh in regard to
hb2 the merger plans for the
new hampshire college and university
system
we've invited dr mckay here today to try
to
provide us some insights as to
uh uh his perceptions of a
merger how it will impact not only just
the fiscal
uh resources but academic resources and
policies of our system so with that
i'd like to welcome ed thank you very
much for taking the time to be with us
today
uh thank you representative led and for
the record
i'm alone in my house in durham if
thank you so um let me start
by saying i really appreciate the
opportunity to speak to the
subcommittee um this is a critical issue
for the state of new hampshire and all
our residents
i mean reading the language of house
bill 2 is primarily focused on
the appointment process for this new
superboard
but it did cite four things that were
the goals and that is to provide
an effective and efficient system of
public higher education that is
affordable
and accessible so i think we should look
at that and see what the current status
is of the current context
for that first the university system of
new hampshire has the highest graduation
rate of any four-year public system in
new england
the community college system has the
highest graduation
rate of any two-year public system
public system in new england so i think
you can check the effectiveness box
in terms of efficiency is documented
by kathy provencher at a presentation
last week to division two
the university system has the lowest
administrative costs of any public
higher education system in new england
and i could not find
comparable data for the community
college system but i think we all know
how administratively lean
they are so i think if we can
acknowledge that they're extremely
efficient so we can check that box and
moreover
um the university system is engaged in a
multi-year process has been for
streamlining its backroom operations
called far
financial and administrative
reorganization that will prove
within the aggregate with other efforts
will produce savings of 70 million
dollars by
fiscal year 2023 their commitment to
efficiency
uh cannot be denied we look at
affordability
we look at the community college system
um
in the last decade has increased its per
credit hour treasury
rate from 210 to 215 dollars
a total of about two percent in a decade
not not per year
over the whole time so they're really
committed to keeping that rate as low as
possible and in fact other community
college systems have
caught up with the university system
given
its rather i think we acknowledge low
level of state
subsidy or state appropriations support
has always had higher
uh tuition rates and it's functioned for
a long time on a
on a higher tuition rate higher aid kind
of philosophy and
for many decades embrace the notion of
well
the out of state tuition rate should be
higher because they provide a subsidy
for the in-state students also in-state
rates should be higher
um and we started this in 1980 on the
advice of a
then governor in that time that go with
a high tuition high rate approach
and we embraced a financial aid package
that we called meeting all need
that that proc that meeting all need
uh existed until uh the legislature
unfortunately can cut the state of
operating appropriation by 50 percent to
the average system
but now it's in a different form with
only dealing with tuition
in the granite guarantee so again the
commitment is there to reducing the net
price
uh for students and sustaining that
affordability
in terms of access i think
we can we know about the commitment of
the community college in particular to
individuals in high school the
long standing success with running start
and under representative lads leadership
support appropriation with support for
gained
gain for dual and concurrent courses
stem courses in support of that they
also have the early college initiative
e-start there's a number of ways in high
school students in new hampshire
can gain college access or college
credits which are then
fully transferable moreover the
community colleges by their very nature
are nimble and respond to local business
needs and i would say that's true also
the university system
if you look at how these systems have
been so effective and efficient
for decades it's because they've been
responsive to student
local state and regional in some cases
even national needs
in terms of student services so there's
a lot of success there
um i want to also mention one aspect
about
the the university system success and
recruiting out of state students
that's been a tremendous economic
benefit for the state of new hampshire
how many of those students then stay in
state
and then feed our pipeline and help
address our workforce
issues not only is it their economic
impact while they're here and paying
tuition and their parents and
family are coming for events but staying
afterwards but also
it enables us to create the critical
mass to offer many academic programs
that would not otherwise be able to been
offered if we were strictly
relying on our in-state population could
we have chemical engineering we have
electrical engineering
without 50 or more of the students being
from out of state
i don't think you have a sufficient
critical mass so that's been critical so
when you look at the
the track record of both systems to date
i think it's been a success
and during this particular time they're
both dealing with the
impact of covid as cathy preventure
testified
160 million dollars in lost revenue and
increased expenses were incurred
as a result of covid and
while there'll be there is state and
federal aid and hopefully more to come
that's only going to cover a fraction
that just compounds it
the the pressures on these these systems
at this time
so now let's look if that's the context
what are the important questions that
need to be
raised in order to fully consider the
the issue before you and are there
alternative paths to take
well again in house bill 2
there are no specific issues raised
let's identify
what are the set of issues to be
addressed and what are the desired
outcomes and why not provide the
opportunity
to the current independent boards to
respond to those
it's it's not sufficient in my
perspective simply state
the creation new super bowl will somehow
accelerate
resolution of perceived issues when
they're not even clear what they are
the current boards really consist of
dedicated individuals
that do represent the experiences and
skills
need to achieve their respective
missions
the 23 person super board essentially
is all uh and will be all individuals
appointed to a political process and we
can walk through the 23
names every in each a case of the
nominations from the
current university system or community
college boards each has to be
individually approved by the governor
before going to executive council
the governor nominates his own five
individuals that's 15. the other eight
are the governor representative from the
house representative from the senate
four commissioners and finally the
chancellor who will be appointed by this
new board
so essentially all political
appointments
i think there is an existing mechanism
that should consideration should be
given to how to examine this
this issue there's a synergies group
made up of representatives from the
community college system and the
university system that's been meeting
since last july
they are collaborating on joint
initiatives and with a particular focus
on
transfer issues and this is really
critically important because
those issues have embedded in them
the need for adherence to meeting
learning outcome expectations
for the respective academic institutions
that are that would be accepting the
these credits and transfer for either an
institutional level or specific program
level so if the real issue that's being
raised
can we facilitate transfer in one manner
another
let's have a group of individuals who
have the expertise and the experience
with regard to those academic issues
deal with it
i do not think there's really any
opportunity for meaningful
cost savings because of the initiatives
because of documented already
efficient operations and the initiatives
all underway in particular
at the university system there is a
mechanism in place
to have the synergies group report to a
legislative body the public higher
education study committee
and if you read the charter of that
committee it says explicitly
the responsibility to study the
operation goals and purposes
organization size and financing of
public higher education in the state
isn't that exactly what this is about so
why not
charge the synergies group or some
entity to make a recommendation
or to analyze whatever the specific
issues that are being raised
and have that entity then recommend
to the public higher education study
committee
their findings report those findings
that again the public higher education
study committee is the entity that was
established to hold the public irish
education systems accountable and then
based on that report
then the public higher education study
committee can make right
recommendations to the legislature about
what actions if any
should be taken and what the timeline is
to accomplish any
measurable outcomes that need to be
addressed so again let's identify what
are the issues that need to be addressed
specifically what are the outcomes what
are the metrics what are the
quantifiable metrics that need to be met
and then have some entity an entity with
the expertise
report back to the public higher
education study committee on the
timeline for doing that maybe the
dollars that will be needed to
accomplish those also and and that seems
to be a more reasonable process and
creating a super board and and no
process for
the subsequent filling of the of those
seats and the
recommendation in my view seems to put
the cart before the horse
and i'm just um suggesting that there
may be
um a better way to approach addressing
whatever issues may be out there
and thank you representative led and i'm
oh i'm sorry i couldn't hear you um
representative lad i think you have
muted i i had myself muted because i got
a little two-year-old running around out
back there and
i i wanted uh to not interfere with what
you were saying but i
i'm sure there's many questions which we
have and so are
you good with just participating with us
for the next hour or so
and and helping us out with some of
the our discussion and questions i am
thank you
thank you ed um so i'll i'll i'll start
out with one question here
and one of the issues that has been
at stake here and and as a pops up in
everybody's mind initially
is our tuition costs for the community
college system
are significantly lower than that of the
uh
the four-year schools even within the
four-year schools we have different
tuitioning
costs um in your uh
working previously with various uh
college and university systems and i'm
sure you have
um and even within uh
in the effort to do these types of
studies like
consolidating our structure and our
organization
have we seen the tuition costs
changed in those districts which have
gone for us in those states where
they've moved forward to
get one overseeing board or
do those disparities between costs
still exist i i think in
general the disparities in cost
still exist however let me say there
because
of those efforts to merge
there is often pressure on
the faculty from the faculty and staff
in the community college system
typically on generalizing here
to raise the compensation levels and to
equalize those things so costs actually
may
increase on that increasing the pressure
to equalize
in some ways the tuition
the the i'm more familiar with the
efforts within
new england although again the end gems
report that was referenced earlier
um does have some national information
and there has been
in that case some national examples but
um i i think there would
it would be critical and again the board
if there was such a merger
that superboy would have to have the
authority
to set tuition um and
one would hope but again um it's unclear
that they would be respectful of the
need of the community college system in
particular
to maintain the lowest cost of a
possible
price because it's not only the reason
the recent high school graduates is all
those adults and part-time learners and
we can talk about the financial aid
available through the 529 commission and
others that will help
address that so i think um
some kinds of differentiation in the
price is absolutely critical going forth
because there's different populations
being served so i'll stop there
thank you very much i'm going to open it
up to uh the committee to ask questions
right now
uh representative miler uh uh thank you
uh
rep representing vlad uh dr mckay
the question one of the questions that
we deal with you currently have
vacancies in both the chancellors of
both systems
they're they're in a uh i believe
they're currently in a search
process to identify uh qualified
applicants etc
what's your recommendation if if this
were to go forward if we were to take
your recommendation to take some time to
really look at this
and have a significant study
looking at the vision of higher
education for the state
and how does this potential merger fit
that particular vision
what's your suggestions on the search
process
that's currently taking place within
both systems
and what would your recommendations be
regarding that that's one of my
questions
that is challenging and to be candid i i
think it will
it's going to impact the ability to hire
the best person for this if there's not
a clear commitment to
maintaining the separate systems if it's
in
in question then i would recommend as
if as a result of your deliberations and
decisions
throughout this legislative process if
if the ultimate answer
of whether to merge or not is still in
question then i would recommend
for the next year hiring another
interim because i think it will
make it more difficult to sustain the
commitment
of an individual for what typically is
at least a four or five year
expectation um because of this uh
cloud that would be hanging over it uh
so until that is
resolved i think there will be an impact
um
unfortunately so you're basically saying
that there should be a suspension
of any further uh um
search for these uh
for the for replacements of these two
positions then
yes i i think that would that would be
my recommendation if i was a candidate
for any position like this
i would want to know that i have the
ability over the next four or five years
to make a difference
and if that's not clear
then i i think that may have may in
some way restrict the african pool now i
know there's been a lot of
um interest expressed in these positions
but that was
may have been prior to this announcement
of the proposed merging
another question i guess i have too is
that it appears if you look at the data
particularly with the community college
that there is
a growing reliance on the use of
adjunct professors vis-a-vis that
full-time now granted there needs to be
a balance
i understand that because in some ways
you want to have
practitioners in the field working with
students
but on the other hand it looks like
perhaps one of the ways that the tuition
at least at the community colleges has
been maintained at a lower rate
is because they use the adjunct
professors which obviously
costs less not as much overhead there's
not as much
benefits etc so one of the concerns i
have is that the reliance on adjuncts
visiting that of full-time professors at
the at the
university level any do you have any
thoughts about that
as it relates to this combining these
institutions
right well let me just say as a
generality throughout new england and
nationally you're seeing greater
reliance on
adjunct part-time sometimes
full-time individuals that are hired as
instructors for example
i and i think part of it is a car saving
but also very importantly it does enable
the institution
to be more nimble to respond to emerging
areas of interest and provide
specific expertise in those those areas
so i
it's a much appreciative and valued
component to the overall faculty
load i i do think the reality going
forward
um given the demographic headwinds
that the state of new hampshire and
all of new england are facing is that i
don't see any
expansion in the ten the number of
tenure track faculty
or nominal expansion and probably
through this period
uh sustaining that number of adjunct
faculty
is that the best for the longer term no
but i think the real
the financial reality facing is that is
where
we are at this point and where we're
likely to be unfortunately for the next
representative ellison i um okay let me
go rick is
taking care of the two-year-old i think
no i just had to
answer the phone the other end so yes go
ahead art uh thank you
uh and thank you ed for for being here
today
uh i i would start by saying i share
mel's concern about the numbers
of adjunct professors in the community
college system
but my question i guess getting down
into the weeds on this
is the synergies group
is there a timeline for them to contin
to
sort of finish their work uh
and the second question is given what's
transpired
in the budget and the reason we're all
talking are they fairly nimble to
start to maybe refocus their work in a
different way because of the urgency of
the situation
i i do not know of a deadline or
timeline for the completion of their
work
i would say this would be their priority
and they would refocus and
for example you could ask them to
complete an analysis of the issues
identified and the specific outcomes uh
desired once those are made by i think
the end of this
calendar year by sometime in the fall so
that that
report could be received by the public
higher education study committee
and i think it would be incumbent um
upon
both of the independent boards now to
ensure that the representatives on that
synergy
group address that issue as their issues
as their top priority so i
would i believe representative ellison
it can and should
uh take precedent over other issues
they're dealing with
now especially if they may relate as i
believe that be the case to the academic
area because there are
mechanisms already in place with regard
to
the finance and administrative structure
uh ed i have a a sort of a follow-up
question when we were talking about the
position of chancellor
and that you have held uh and in
speaking
with our two past chancellors uh
roscatel and todd leach
i was informed um that the chancellor
position
in this state is not as strong as it is
in some other states in terms of
statutory authority
uh is that in our restructuring process
um obviously we're still i would think
going to need to have chancellors or
is there any need for us to address that
position which
the duties of the chancellor and the
authority of the chancellor verse those
of the presidents of the various
institutions
so the the question was you know it for
you ed
dr mckay um
the authority of the chancellor versus
the authority of the presidents of the
colleges and the universities
um do we have to look at those job
descriptions
and responsibilities if we're going to
go through a restructuring process
absolutely i attempt to attempt to talk
through it
and without getting too much in the
weeds i believe
that based on personal experience and my
observations and other systems
the chancellor of the system
ought to be the the ceo and that all the
presidents
ought to report to that chancellor that
was
the procedure and and internal
in the university system until 2013
um i didn't i left at that time
because i believed it was not in the
best long-term interest of the
functioning of the system
to have the president's report directly
as a board i understand
and todd dealt with that so i now i
think there is some revisiting of that
and so again my personal bias
on this is that there ought to be a
single ceo
that the board can hold accountable for
the results of the performance of the um
institutions and their respective ceos
i do not believe in staff that's a
problem
i think that's a internal problem to
each of
the governing boards if not sufficient
latitude and authorities given to the
chancellor
thank you very much dr mckay um are
there
uh questions from from the committee i
see a uh uh
dr ford yes uh dr mckay
um i'm a former ace fellow and i've been
involved in some of these uh
merger things minnesota in particular
as well as massachusetts um one of the
things that bothered me most
in the n champs report was the fact that
when they merged into systems of one
system
only one shall we say category
wound up getting the real attention and
that that concerned me a great deal
because then they go on to ask for
something like system-wide
uh accreditation and
i think that if you get too far behind
on the institution you don't know what
you're accrediting
i representative for i share your
concerns and i think that is a a
particular issue that needs to be
addressed as part of your deliberations
with regard to the issue i
i i think the community college
is committed to its its mission i think
the
individuals on that board are committed
to it and addressing
local business needs local and i do
worry that they're
that would not always be the case if the
systems emerged
i mean in the university system we
worked hard to
make sure that each institution within
the system
had a distinctive aspect to it
unh was a land grant sea grant space
grant institution
plymouth regional public university
king ko plaque which is a public liberal
arts college
granite state was a focused on adult
learners throughout this
so we wanted to maintain the
distinctiveness of each of those
entities and i do worry as
you you create a larger system that some
of those
will be less attention paid to those
distinctive needs
and that one institution may have a
disproportionate
thank you so i'd like to follow that up
with either
you know the past president of of lowell
or the you know the past chancellor for
the university system now
do we have uh some evidence out there
that where these consolidations have
been made
and what occurs or occurred
is similar to what dr ford was
referencing
uh is that as something that
is quite possibly going to happen where
the the mission
of the community college system becomes
lost
or the mission to engage in
certification pathways which build
two skills is that going to get lost
versus the
uh the traditional four-year uh degree
masters and going on with doctoral
programs
i think that's a risk i i i have
characterized
this initiative as high risk low reward
and that would be one of the risks that
okay thank you um one other question i
don't see people putting their hands up
so if you put your hands up i can
see it but we have a declining
demographic
in this state obviously k-12 population
has just dropped off significantly we
all know that and we've all thrown
around the
you know the figures um and so that
certainly uh shrinks the pool of
eligibility or
pool students which are going to go on
to a
system here in new hampshire and of
course we have the issue
of competition that's occurring from
others other states around us
namely you know massachusetts and maine
so uh in dealing with this
we can deal with it as vermont maybe did
by
increasing the number of out-of-state
students so we start
having you know the money come in
through the tuition
that i think's a catch-22 for vermont
they're at the point now where there's
up
close to 70 80 percent out-of-state
students and and it's
it's still in economic trouble
we also have the situation where we may
have duplication of various departments
from keene to plymouth to unh
have we looked at consolidation of
programs
to certain locations within our state so
we can
eliminate some of its duplicity so
demographics is
causing some issues uh are there any
ways to resolve this issue
without having to change our whole
structure and organization uh ed
i believe there are um let me just say
you cited uvm which it does have less i
saw 78
of its um students were out of state but
that's separate from
the vermont um college and community
college
system which is really struggling um
they
merged lyndon and johnson state colleges
in the northern
vermont university now they're merging
that with
castleton and so there's a lot of issues
there and they do not
have um that proportion of out-of-state
students
again the universe system has been very
the residential campus is very effective
but it will be a continuing challenge
and as i mentioned that part of the
critical issue here is this critical
mass with
offer programs so i think one of the
things to
to um look to in the future and some
campuses are beginning to the university
of maine system is being explored that
to have
a program hosted primarily at one
campus and one department but then
offered in multiple
sites so that students have access to
programs wherever they may
attend i think with the pivoting to
various methods of academic program
delivery
last spring there is much more comfort
and expertise with regarding to deliver
programs online especially from our
traditionally residential campuses than
there had been previously
so i think that actually has opened the
door to more of
these opportunities and if in
enrollments at a particular residential
campus
decline and but you can offer students
on that residential campus the
same access or maybe greater access to
other
academic programs that may be primarily
housed at another
uh institution i i think that is a
an opportunity to be explored and i
think we'll see more of that
that is program sharing if you will
or ways to enable individuals
throughout the state to gain act greater
access to programs that may be primarily
thank you art uh
thank you rick uh ed just a question
about
uh financing which obviously
we don't have an answer to yet but there
appears to be
uh some feeling on the part of some
people that a merger
will result in cost savings down the
road
uh just your view of
sort of that issue and how possible that
is
and yeah how possible that would be
based on your experience uh within the
state
and your knowledge of other states
i thank you representative ellison for
that question i
and as documented previously the
university system and the community
college system
already have very low administrative
costs
and the university system is engaged in
this far
effort finance and administrative
reorganization to
further reduce those costs i think the
whatever
incremental um savings would be
available through this merger are de
minimis
i mean i i i don't i think no one should
expect that there'd be any
substantive financial savings
i just want to be candid about that i
see no evidence for that
thank you transferability of credits
okay
go ahead dave you go first yeah yeah no
worries rick um and
and um i i was going to ask about that
too but i'll hold off on that one
um because i know that's one of the
things that that i think the governor
was talking about
specifically but but um i wanted to
ask you dr mckay about um other
sort of i don't want to call them sort
of accessory
you know issues that that that might
come up during
during um during a merger but things
like um
like you know system foundations and
things like that
what sort of considerations um have to
sort of be looked at um about those
types of things
thank you just for the record i chair
the
foundation for new hampshire community
colleges and
several members of that board you met
yesterday
are appointed from the governing board
the board of trustees of the community
college system now
if there is no longer a governing board
what what are the impact
in my personal view is because there has
not been a history
of advancement and development in the
community college system
it's absolutely essential that that
that function that is development a
system-wide
foundation for the community college be
in place because
uh i don't believe another entity uh
unh or could could serve those needs and
the amount of time that's spent with the
advisory committees on the different
campuses
on the community college campuses going
there me
and trying to build an expectation for
development and support it is critical
so those are
the kind of the issues
uh the unintended consequences i think
that could result
from a rush to merger
okay thanks so there are there other
things that would sort of fall into
that category of i
well i i um the law school at unh has
its own you know
advisor unh manchester i think there are
other
entities that have different
relationships and different
um appointments coming from the
governing board
i have not seen the most recent list of
that so i might i
shouldn't state that because i'm not
that familiar with the current
but i there are relationships there and
again
being built with the local communities
that host these campuses and their
businesses and
um i just if you look at what the
i'll pick on the community colleges
again what they've done in terms of
relationship with local businesses and
securing support for students during
cove at 19 time
and and responding to specific training
and credentialing
that that's going to be helpful to as
these businesses re-emerge
it's moral i will that attention still
be paid if there was only one
entity i i don't know that's a
question okay great no thanks thanks
very much ed
i i've got a question regarding i know
that
there are um
labor contracts at keene state
at unh at uh at the
community college uh what's your
experience and how those uh
collective bargaining agreements are
i think there is likely to be impact
down the road as you i
believe is something like 10 or 11
different union agreements between the
two systems
um and it's hard for me to imagine that
as
if you're representing a group of
employees at x you don't look at
what's the provisions for benefits at
why and saying
well if those are better than what we
have shouldn't we be
equalized under a single system
so i do think again that may be one of
those unintended consequences that
um that will result as a
yeah that's going to be a very difficult
one with the compensation and terms and
conditions of various contracts
and it i can't help but think it's going
to end up with having some more costs
to try to equalize that out or try to
come to a if we're going to go that
direction towards some kind of a single
contract for certain groups
well and then the other it's also uh
complex because you've got different
international unions representing
various different
different contracts so it's not like
you've got one universal representative
throughout the system so
you've got those entities would have to
be dealt with from
yeah yes representative ford
more than just that problem which i
don't think is an impossible problem
it's just simply
having to go through the process being a
former union president myself
it is just you're going to have to sit
down and negotiate all those
the more difficult thing in making
equations with people have
who have apparent equal status if you
will as a professor
is that they don't have equal status in
the marketplace
right and so now you're getting people
who are in high demand in industry
wanting to be paid more than someone who
just teaches
that subject quote unquote and so
you get into all of those kinds of
rather nasty
internacing kind of fights and they are
nasty
i know i've i've lived through a couple
of them so
for our uh representative how long does
it take to get resolution on these
okay but you do
finally reach a working agreement
because you don't have any choice
and they don't have any choice we've all
got to work together
somehow and so you sort of hammer out
but you have to do it they're almost all
individual
yeah the one thing i'd say with my
experience with the university system
and it may be an issue here is that when
the university system was created
employees at keene and plymouth were
part of the state
union and so it took which is a defined
benefit program not a defined
contribution
so it took there was a phase-out program
and
and eventually all employees in the
university became part of
our 403 b which is a defined
contribution program
but i think a similar issue would exist
here is that a number of individuals in
the
community college system are part of the
state pension program to be able to find
benefit
um which makes it more problematic
to negotiate a resolution on that
because of the
embedded benefits and the time uh that
one may have in that particular program
but i agree with you it's possible and i
also agree with you the
faculty salaries for business faculty
versus
um a question for you ed um
some people equate this and i've
mentioned i think in the committee
several times
it's like marching down the football
field on your 50-yard line you want to
get to the end zone with a hail mary
pass
rather than going incrementally down the
field
and looking at our four-year system
right now
granite state plymouth keene unh
have to the best of your knowledge have
we
had any kind of an effort to move
forward in merging
those systems into a system whereas
a course title in one situation in keene
is the same title in another
plymouth state and you get the same
three credits
and they're transferable between
departments it i understand maine is
trying to work through something like
this right now they have
all those satellites they expanded in
the 70s and 80s
to augusta to lewiston to presque isle
to carry you know all over
and now they're finding they can't
afford to keep those locations afloat
so this transferability of credit is
really important do we merge that first
amongst
one level and then try to go
to the larger scope of structure and
organization
i think that's a good question i think
that would be a question to the
synergies group how to approach
a lot of that there has been adoption of
a
common learning management system but i
think in terms of the actual titling
and and you also find there's variances
now there's
three credit courses uh like kane and
other places for credit and
unh and so forth so part of it is
there's a number of things to
to resolve with that and i think if if
that is a specific concern
with regard to students transferring and
i don't uh know that it hasn't been
addressed to a great extent then um it
it should be
to create creation of a common student
information system
across both systems
is would be a very big project and would
cost a lot of money
so i i i think that and take time
um so i think that is the kind of
question that could be posed
and um would take some research
and and then you'd have more information
to the deal to
help you to define what the best path
forward is
representative ford yes dr mckay
when i was at lowell where i was not the
president by the way i was the assistant
to the president
but i was the president at southwest
minnesota state
okay just to clarify my my
bio here but we ran in when we were
merged with the community colleges
we ran into a situation in which our
introductory math course for example
had was being taught at the community
college
and you looked at the course description
and their
course description was exactly one
third of what we described in our course
that we taught and so we finally had to
have said
we're going to go by the competency
achieved
in the course we'll give you the credits
as free electives
right we're going to go by fulfilling
requirements based on
what you did in the course and that
proved to be
pretty reasonably acceptable yeah
representative ford raises a good issue
and that is what are the learning
outcomes i know you have
an individual who really has expertise
coming to a future
in this arena with regard to
accreditation learning outcomes and so
forth
coming to a future meeting and that
would be a good conversation to have
with her
um but you're absolutely right there are
learning outcomes for specific programs
and institutions and if you're accepting
transfer and what were the learning
outcomes from those particular courses
um and how do they mesh them with the
program requirements at your
host institution so yes those are
that that's why there are um it's
difficult to find simple answers to a
lot of these transfer issues unless you
do a
pipe two plus two problem which do exist
a lot of places but you know
associate degree and accepting that
package and
that's that's helpful but if you're
talking about individual courses
or taking three courses here and one
course here
there are a lot of challenges in that
because again
the institution needs to protect its
integrity with regard to awarding
ultimately awarding of its degrees and
making sure its learning outcomes
are met for individuals who they're
granting their agree to so
as you suggested that analysis needs to
be done
yeah i can i do a follow-up on that one
rick sure go for it dave
so so thanks and oliver that was a that
was an excellent question and um
and i think you know dr mckay's response
on that i've i've
i've served um i think 20 plus years
on the unh engineering technology
program board
and on the nhti advisory board
and so there's always been a very very
close relationship
in a two plus two program where students
in engineering technology at the
community colleges
have a seamless um
transfer into the into unh
and uh uh when i began on it it was unh
at durham it's now unh in manchester
but it's been a very very successful
program but
it wasn't at all easy to make sure
that that students particularly in the
math courses
had what they need coming out of high
school getting into
you know going to nhti for example and
then
transferring into um into the
engineering technology program
at unh and so so even for
one very well established program it
required a tremendous amount of effort
on the part of you know essentially
faculty to um
to to make that um um make that happen
and and i guess you know uh one it
sounds like one of the concerns would be
um you know how do you go about
um making that happen on a broader basis
um
and and i i i don't know if that would
be easier under one system or
or or what
so yeah i based on the n champs report
i'm not sure would be easier under one
system i think that's one of the things
they cite is
the expectation was it was going to be
easier but when you get down to the
nitty-gritty if you will
it's just as you suggest you have to
look at those learning outcomes and
align those so the individual
earning the degree has met those
expectations
yeah yeah no thank thanks very much dr
mccann
yeah you have a question art yes i do
please thank you rick
uh and you may not know this one because
it gets down into the weeds i understand
some of the issues between transferring
credits from the community college
system
up into the college university system
and i this question is probably for
somebody at the community college system
is there sort of are there differences
between courses
and credits from the individual
community college campuses for instance
on math 101
is math 101 pretty much the same across
the board
at the community college i
it is a question that would be better
addressed to uh chancellor hubert
um but based on my prior conversations
with
chancellor cattell i know that enormous
amount of work was being done across the
system
to um equalize those or to make
to resolve those kind of issues so i
don't want to say definitively that
many of those issues have been addressed
but i know they were being addressed and
but whether they're resolved or not i
just don't know
thank you just just to follow up to what
where
art's coming from and and i've heard
others
speaking the same way here um we've
heard
from beth dorian over at the community
college system
at a high percentage of of students
leaving high school that are coming into
the community college
they as well as adults uh are not
prepared for mathematics
yeah and they we at times have had as
high as 60 percent
of those incoming uh individuals
require remedial mathematics when i've
talked before to several college
presidents of our four years i don't
want to mention names of those
presidents
they've indicated to us on the committee
that they don't have remediation at the
four-year level
we we have it at the two-year level but
of that sixty percent that
come in fifty percent never come out
with a degree
um i'm fearful that if we lose
this uh access that we have through the
community college system
that we're going to lose a number of
students
that i have hopes of getting a degree in
a higher level of education
would this program in your perspective
ed
be somewhat lost if we start emerging
uh everything our academic program our
accreditation
um of the various two years and four
years into one accreditation
if that's the route we go um or we can
lose something
well if if you go that route one
accreditation that's a
very big jump and especially if you
would combine two-year institutions and
four-year institutions uh
the university of maine system is just
looking at all their four-year
institutions and the unified
accreditation and again that's a good
question for one of your
future yes but let me say and i want to
applaud the work that the community
college system has done in
embracing what they call complete
college america initiatives and that
in in not having
students take these remedial courses
that don't count
for credit uh towards a degree but what
they
have done is expanded them so the
remedial plus if you will
and they they have extra time and that
they convert those
into courses that then by measuring the
learning outcomes again
they can count towards satisfying degree
requirements for the two-year degree and
then if there's a two plus two
transfer so it really is helping so many
of those students who may come
to the community colleges not fully
prepared to
succeed and that's one of the critical
aspects of the community college again
being able to work
and with those students and provide more
attention and hands-on support maybe
then
would reside otherwise and again some of
the initiatives that have been embraced
by the community college system
have i think been very effective at um
elevating
students so that they are prepared to
succeed at post-secondary education
thank you uh yes
dave yeah thanks thanks rick so um
ed something that's that's come up um
certainly it's come up at nhti but i
think it's probably come up at other
community colleges too
where where there is a um
a unique opportunity to to
possibly provide a baccalaureate degree
at the community community college level
in a
um in a in a course or in a
sorry in a program of studies that isn't
offered let's say
you know it through the university
system and
and i was uh i guess i was wondering is
is that something that um that
could could have been improved you know
improve the um the uh
degree attainment potential for
students under the existing separate
systems or
or under under a combined system
that's a good question i again i'll
express my personal
bias here i would rather in those
circumstances where there's
identification for a need of a
bachelor's program
with um then i would
prefer uh collaboration with the
university system one of the
institutions that's best aligned
to serve that need and to partner with
that including the potential delivery on
the nhdi campus
of that four full years because as you
all know
many of those individuals may be place
bound and not able to
travel to plymouth or wherever to
complete a degree so
i i think again this is the kind of
collaboration i think that they're
seeking
through the synergies group and other
initiatives and i i'm optimistic about
those
uh producing those kinds of results and
whether that happens um under a merger
or not i don't know
okay in the past
ed i've talked with todd and asked him
the question should the community
college system be
issuing a four-year degree and of course
he was objecting to that but i talked to
roscatel and they've oftentimes come
before the education committee saying
well they'd like to have some programs
which can
engage you know a four-year certificate
would you see this happening
uh with a merger
i don't know if that's a necessary
outcome and again my bias is to
have each of the systems ideally
maintain their
distinctive features and focus i also
think
it begins to blur that line about
compensation for faculty going back
there
and it it again may create unintended
consequences and
challenges down the road if you start to
initiate
the deliver the awarding of four-year
degrees on the community college
campuses um so
i i think there are issues embedded in
that
now well along that along that same line
the one of the things that was cited um
by the governor
was the competition for students
with a diminishing number of
students in school and graduating et
cetera
is the competition of how do you attract
students to to come and one of the one
of the points you make in your
presentation is the uh the the unh
system
helps to get people from out of state to
come into the state
but uh how do you look at the issue of
the question of
a student competing to get students
uh on campus i
i think that's an excellent question and
i think that some of the
the dual admission programs that grants
um great bay
community college as with unh i think
more initiatives like that so
you can so the university system the
community college system could market
and communicate to new hampshire high
school students
here's a pathway for you here's a lower
cost pathway for your first two years at
community college you may where you may
be able to commute to
it and then you all your credits are
transferred in the 2 program
and that you're able to complete that
degree with relatively low levels
of student debt and and again
financial aid is you know particularly
important here in providing that aid
we've mentioned that i've mentioned
before the granite can guarantee
i think there are ways to
market the this capacity to earn four
two and four-year degrees at a a lower
price tag which
makes collectively the public systems in
new hampshire
more competitive without out-of-state
offerings
um i think that's exactly the kind of
initiative that should be embraced and i
think is being embraced but we've seen
some examples of it but expanded
um and i think it would be very helpful
to say i i share those concerns as many
of you know i've been involved in what
they've called 65 by 25 for a number of
years
so i am concerned about our future
workforce needs
but but with that said the merger
this could happen even without any kind
of a merger then
absolutely it does exist yeah right
exactly just you just need to ramp it up
it's what you're saying you just wrap
up the opportunity ramp it up and and
maybe special
support from our like like
representative led secured uh
state support for dual and current
enrollment in stem courses
now that is an important initiative to
have students
earn college level or credit
for stem courses before going on maybe
there's a special
support appropriation for marketing of
this these pathways that
let them identify the pathways whatever
i i do agree it's an issue and we need
to work on it
ed can you talk a little bit about
granite guarantee
where does the funding come from for
granted guarantee i thought that was
only for a four-year school
i'm sorry it is only offered by the
residential campuses within the
university system in new hampshire i
wasn't clear about that
but what they did what the university
system did two years ago i believe
they said if you're a graduate of the
community college system and you meet
the criteria which is your pedal
eligible and you're going full time
and you then we will extend that to you
and basically what it says it provides
last dollar support such that there's no
net cost for tuition
so if you're pell eligible and you've
got two or three
whatever the the let's say it's ten
thousand dollar or eleven thousand
dollars for tuition of
plymouth whatever the current figure
maybe thirteen thousand let's say
thirteen thousand and your your um pell
grant is four thousand um through other
packages
uh including the unique endowment payout
and others that institutional aid
the institution will commit to so that
you
um your full need is met for tuition it
doesn't cover room and board
but that's an important marketing piece
and
again i'm hopeful that those kinds of
[Music]
opportunities can be expanded
enough but you're right it only goes to
the three residential
uh universities and camps now so so ed
where is the revenue come from
for this for the the university to have
these funds to help a kid would grant it
guarantee
is it out of the the the assets that the
four years have that the community
college does not have
yes that's that's true um sorry my
phone's ringing in the background but
yes i um just
the um yes the the university system
uh awards a great deal of financial aid
to both in-state and out-of-state
students and
in prioritizing this initiative they
looked at the
assets they had including again the
payoff from the unique endowment and
others uh sources other grants and gifts
that have been
you know to provide scholarship funds
and that and they've awarded those so
let me just again so yes
thank you uh alvar
thank you uh i have
advocated for years now with students
that the easiest way to reduce the cost
of education
is to not interrupt it with summers
simply go straight through
and you can get out in two and a half
years with a bachelor's degree
that be something that with community
colleges in concert and so forth
it might be possible to get more people
to think in those terms
i absolutely absolutely agree and i
think that's a wonderful idea
and let me go back though the fact that
some high school students are earning
significant number of college credits
now through the various community
college initiatives in fact
i i just saw yesterday a preview of what
will be announced soon
an student graduating from high school
in new hampshire
um will earn her associate's degree
several months after
graduating from high school so that is
exactly the kind of thing we're trying
to
is everybody is anybody able to hear ed
right now
i apologize i have some uh
internet connection issues here so um
i i'm not sure but i i'm embracing uh
the notion
and cited the fact that uh again we we
have an example of a student
who um i've been having a problem two
this morning
yeah yeah so i i
a student who would graduate high school
and regret earning associate degrees
soon thereafter so
um i think that is the kind of thing we
in vermont i'm sorry i didn't
hear that question i'm sorry i i just i
was going to confirm
what you said about vermont earlier i
was on a castleton's
knee ask visit and therefore their
foreign students i.e from new york just
quit coming after a while they would
come there for two years
and ski and then they would go back home
and get their degree from a local place
yeah and eventually that just quit
happening and it was
very bad on them for enrollments yeah
uh ed when you were a chancellor for the
university system
and you must have been seeing some of
the
departments within the university system
uh at various college location
university locations
which were being funded through revenues
via other departments in other words the
student attendance in these programs was
is shrinking sort of like our
law school now in the center part of the
state here
um are there any programs that you know
of that
that need consolidation
or maybe it's time to say that maybe
we'll have that done through reciprocity
with another state school in another
state
like maine has their physical therapy
kids coming to unh
maine doesn't have such a program is
there room for us to try
to have a little bit more reciprocity
with uh
and work agreements with some of these
other state universities
well yes and in fact the the vehicle
exists for that and that's the new
england board of higher education or
nebby
nebby has this regional tuition program
where if a program is not offered in
your state
you can get the in-state rate to
participate in that program
in that state for example there's no
pharmacy program in the state of new
hampshire so new hampshire
students can go to rhode island to go
for their their
pharmacy program the nebby program has
been established for 20-some years
and is a viable vehicle for
allowing students those opportunities
we wanted to attract a lot of out of
state students and so we
to new hampshire residential campuses so
that we had the
capacity to offer as many programs that
we thought
met the state needs but if you're as we
look collectively the demographics
across new england you may see
rick i'm gonna have to drop now okay
dave
but but i want to thank you very much
and thank you very much ed
it's great to see you this morning and
um
and we'll we'll see you back on uh on
this real soon
so everyone have a great weekend all
um thank you very much dave good luck
this afternoon
um alumni associations ed are extremely
important and alumni associations at unh
are probably
i i'm just making a guess are much
stronger than they are at nhti
um nhgi does a good job by the way with
30. so let me say of
of all the uh community colleges they
may be have the strongest
i think they do have the strongest
association
do alumni associations and of course
this is our perception or
you know more of a a guess
would if they see that their university
is going to come underneath the roof
of a larger global structure system
structure
do you think there would be a chance
that you would see
fewer gifts in terms of finances going
to that institution or
alumni contributions are very important
to unh
yes i i um
i don't see that much having much impact
on you and age because
it's really distinct but let me say i
think pennsylvania is looking at some of
those issues
now consolidating in two different cases
three
campuses into one i
i think most donors identification
is with particular institution not with
a system
so what we have found over the years
is that while you want to support
um collective fundraising by backroom
operations such as the foundation for
new hampshire community colleges
does and the v the
asking primarily if not almost
exclusively but primarily has to come
from the particular
institution that has the affiliation
with that
that individual or that association and
individuals do give back to institutions
yes there are some gifts received at a
system level
and they're very appreciated but i have
to say the great majority i think that
is a
if there was some blending of brand and
identification
um then i think there's a potential to
lose some
some aspect of giving you mentioned
the pennsylvania higher education system
that's an interesting system they have
the commonwealth
uh system of higher education which
involves 14 different institutions
however one of those
institutions penn state has 23 units
within
it and so they have a separate uh system
called the penn state
higher education system
and within their system i always thought
temple university was
a private in philadelphia but that's
part of the commonwealth system
so does the university of pittsburgh
university of pittsburgh temple
yeah and and penn state essentially
functions independently then they have a
state university system as you said with
14 institutions and that's
where two pairs of three um those three
institutions can be combined in one case
three others and in other kings
yeah very different model that uh
that works uh of course that might be a
question for don burks too because he
was a chancellor within that system
i'll wait and hold that one okay
are there further questions of uh ed
right now he's been with us now for
an hour and 15 or 20 minutes it's quite
a lengthy period
um representative ellison may have a
question
yes art
that's better thank you going back to
the math question
i'm pretty familiar with how the
community college system has
made those changes to with students who
come in without
the need in math skills and i applaud
them for that because by putting those
into the credit situation
then students are not pulling off their
pell grant money without getting any
any credits given that situation and i
just want to be a little clear
how does unh or plymouth or keene handle
that if the same student comes in
who is has some limited math
do you have some sense of that no i as
representative lad said earlier the
position of the university system has
been historically and
um i admit i don't have real current
information but
their their position was there were no
remedial courses there
and that uh students sought
support from from the faculty members or
maybe from other students to help them
through that i think that
was more challenging for them okay
thank you that's helpful thank you uh i
have one last question i've been sort of
holding off on it
uh for you ed it deals with the new
governing board and you spoke about this
at the very beginning
and when i look at the community college
system now they're
very closely aligned with regional
business
when i look at the university system new
hampshire and that board of trustees
i i see a number of folks which are are
government related various departments
um
represented from the house and the
senate by way
of the president and the speaker
you have folks from the various
department of agriculture the
on all the departments it's it's a much
different makeup
of a board than you have at the
community college level
and you spoke about the new board being
politically appointed um does that
and our are what you trying to say is
that by
we might be missing that element of
tying our education to
uh current changing needs of our
business community
by not having business oriented people
on on
on the overarching board well i and i
think
i think that is a concern um
again one of the individuals i know that
you're going to have soon
has just written a paper
or a publication for the association of
governing boards which
talks about the composition
and the challenges to governing boards
now and do they have the individuals in
that board
with the right set of experiences and
skills
and perspectives to enable
that respective board institution to
move forward in a strategic
manner so it's unclear from me
unclear to me given the appointment
process that's embedded
in house bill 2 how there'll be
assurances that
all those perspectives in terms of the
local state and regional economic needs
and different
needs are going to be addressed in that
composition
there's no
[Music]
no assurance of that at this point
may be the intent but again
[Music]
it's not possible to infer that based on
the information that's currently
available
thank you are there any more questions
for ed at this time
yes fraps and milor uh thank you rick
one of the questions i have you know you
have the unh
at least uh its brand is this what is
the leading in
in research institution in the in the
state
how does that brand then relate
to the vision of the community college
which is different than that brand how
do
how do you see the merging of those two
different visions coming together
i i think they the branding would have
to under any scenario must
remain distinct i think the
unh appropriately brands itself as a
a carnegie one research institution
um attracts students from across the
country and
internationally and um again
with its land-grant sea grant space
grant designations
offers the opportunity for students to
do high
end research and though again
that experience is different than what
may appeal to other
individuals and whatever happens
has to ensure that those uh institutions
whatever their respective
mission is are able to continue to
market that
if it's blurred in any way that will
potentially
put it at risk their ability to
successfully continue
uh ed i'm looking at some of the
structures that connecticut has
with their their uh academic of the
connecticut board of regents for higher
education
they have both financial and academic
authority
uh do you have any familiarity with
connecticut
in terms of do they still have their
boards for the community college
and the university system below this
they may have advisory boards for those
different campuses
i do not believe they have any governing
boards any longer but i'm not sure
and of course you know uconn is not part
of that
that system so it's just the former
state universities colleges and the
community college that were put into
that
that that board um i think again susan
hughes
or others that have had experience in
that system
um would be better able to tell you
about some of their experiences
okay going through that process which
has been challenging
so uconn is a stand-alone university
that's correct and receives separate
appropriation funding separate board of
trustees etc
thank you okay um
well we are we're not uh 11
20 here um are there any more questions
for
dr mckay from the
other two three folks left here
not seeing it ed we really appreciate it
thanks
ed thank you thank you all for for
taking the time and for listening i
very much appreciate the work you do
the legislature establishes the policy
for the executive branch to put him
implement and i know
i it's in good hands whatever this
decision may be i have faith and
confidence in the individuals
representing the legislature to make the
right decision thank you
for for the rest of the committee right
now then
[Music]
what we have coming up and and i'll i'll
try to make sure did
did everybody get there was a report
that was put out that
mike moffitt asked for from the
education commission of the states
uh did did you receive that one
he he asked the question and they
responded you were inquired about state
examples of post-secondary system
mergers including those
which created a single statewide
governance structure
and they responded with a a brief which
was
uh four pages long or a little longer
that um
i got it i i okay it came through to me
okay good uh because at the latter part
of that there
there were some uh they compared to some
other states
and i thought the their their summary
are
there's a a section there on page three
of that report
which gave an overview of post-secondary
institutional mergers with some of the
key questions which need to be resolved
that's something we want to might look
at in terms of
questions that we might be asking the
practitioners
which are going to be with us on
wednesday the practitioners are those
that have been presidents of
of university colleges and that and one
of those practitioners will
is also the chancellor for the community
college system
today the other practitioner is don
burks who was a chancellor with the
penn state system uh out in
bay run that's the penn state university
in erie pennsylvania which is an
engineering school
and uh that there's some very
interesting questions that that
need to be answered regarding that
system because some of the differences
in courses that are
supposedly transferable are not accepted
because uh
they were done at a a school which
didn't come up with those types of
standards that
we have been talking about with ed mckay
so um and then we have barbara
brittenham coming up on
on friday and barbara is
one that's very familiar with the
crediting in fact she is
the individual with the old knee ass
program out of boston that is seen as
misaccrediting for the country she's
she's it
good that's good yeah rick rick
i've got a question for oliver allard
when you were when you were at lowell
did you say that you guys did go through
some kind of a consolidation
uh yeah in your experience when we were
there originally the
the first push was merging lowell tech
and lowell state
into one university and then it got
caught up into
becoming part of umass lowell and then
the state system and all of that
sort of tumbled one thing into another
so so the tech the tech program and this
college program then came together
in that merger with the with umass
that's how i became
uh an aft union president and when we
merged
we agreed to join nea if i was the
president
okay and that's how we settled that
issue with the faculty
and then so i became an nea president
and then i became an ace fellow and went
into college administration
okay all right so how long did that
merger take place oliver
what was it uh done uh um over how many
years it wasn't wasn't all that long i
mean it happened fairly fast
i don't remember exactly because i was
away for part of it
i'm the end of it how much it went but i
remember meeting
with the community colleges and haggling
out courses and things like that
and they got a new person in from
florida who was all
hot and bothered and wanting to push
ahead to community colleges
we didn't have any problem with that we
just wanted equatability
and so how did the how did these uh how
did the cbas
merge the collective bargaining uh what
was the only one
i was in any part of merging was the one
when the university merged
and we worked it out between us
and did the compensation uh was there a
leveling of the compensation or
and benefits item was not there for the
partner
outside like going to community colleges
i was not there when when that because
their requirements for credentials
are different from the university so
you know you you're you're getting
someone with fewer credentials
so i wasn't there for that but i would
imagine it it
still they're still operating on a
community college system
and a university system so when you went
through all this
oliver was there when that was occurring
in working with the community college
system
did the community college mission
become subordinate to that of the
baccalaureate degree programs
and i mean i i had never
no sense of that at all
okay because that's something i taught
at nj mass bay and i taught it
i i think that's a major concern that
folks are having
that you know we don't want to lose
sight of the certification programs that
the
community college is doing and those
two-year programs which are so necessary
for regional business
yeah i think i thought ed brown i
thought i thought ed
brought an important point and that's
the
the role of the uh the the public
higher education um oversight committee
the study committee
and its role its potential role in this
thing which
has not been mentioned i i mean this is
the first time he had mentioned it
and you and i uh rick had talked about
this before but
it seems to me that this is a from a
statute standpoint
it is a governing process that needs to
be engaged in this thing i would think
yeah and for our our our committee
members here i'll give you the statutory
reference for that
uh because i i was looking at this
so 187 dash a
colon 28 and then there's dash a small a
and basically here's what it says in the
last part of that public education study
committee
there it says the study committee shall
be composed of eight members
and shall examine the goals purposes
organization and financing of public
higher education in new hampshire
and shall evaluate and make
recommendations on the university of new
hampshire
plymouth state university keene state
college granite state college
and the community college system of new
hampshire
so that that uh education study
committee
really has oversight over organization
and structure yeah it does yeah
by statute so so it seemed to be that
any kind of a study committee
that's looking at this merger would
ultimately have to make some
recommendation to that group that would
then
deal with whatever legislative changes
that need to take place
or if if this this committee chooses
not to engage i guess we're you know
defaulting on our obligation to
fulfill this duty that's been assigned
to us so uh
i i for one am going to be contacting
ruth ward
and because i'm assuming that she is the
chair of this commission
committee now uh seeing that she's the
chair of
uh senate education yeah also i also
need to check with the speaker because i
the the speaker is the one who basically
makes those appointments to go to that
study committee and i would assume
with the change of administration that
there may be a change
because remember to my surprise i
chaired that last year
yeah and and i would assume there's
going to be new people on that and
if that hasn't been appointed i would
assume that he should uh
move uh forth with that give me that
that's been done mel
oh it has okay good great okay so the
the k
the committee can go ahead but it got
him it has to be called by the senate
yeah right exactly yes ago there was a
time when
john reagan had it yeah and then um at
one point in time i believe i don't
think ruth
ruth was on that but she never was
cheering it i think she was on it during
your tenure yes correct yeah
and so and i can remember that when i
chaired it
reagan was on it and i think
alessandro was on it but
yeah it's it's something that we got to
get on top of
i think also in we're going to be
talking
next week on wednesday with the two
individuals
you know i've mentioned i'd be looking
at that report that comes out of the
national center for
higher education management um systems
and those 10 questions on page 27 of
that report
very good are very very good questions
we need to discuss those questions
we also want to look at you know some of
the information
before that which they deal with these
different states that have gone through
some of this consolidation
um i i'd be you know
interested in and really looking at what
happened in minnesota and connecticut
i'm not too concerned what happened
alaska i'm familiar what happened there
and it's just a whole different ball
game than
tiny new hampshire it doesn't have the
geographic issues that
we have here um they also didn't really
have the demographic issues as well at
that time
so is our role here rick uh as we
move forward on this in the next two
meetings is to come up with a series of
questions
for division two uh exactly what is
uh representative umberger uh looking
for
for our group to to give to her
yeah she's looking for basic information
and facts
and considerations so um
we've heard a lot of that today i'm
going to go back and listen to
streaming here and try to extract from
that
some of these particular issues that
need consideration we're not going to
have resolution today no
no and we it's impossible uh one of the
issues that's
popping up is timeline you know what's
the timeline for this transfer and what
are the associated costs
to go through a restructure there's
going to be some sideways
costs and that's what i've i've had that
indicated to me by both the
community college system and the
university system
uh i don't see that in the budget well i
i also
thought uh ed's comment regarding about
suspending the search process
um is a good one because frankly
uh if how are they going to get
candidates who are going to
who know that this is possible how are
they going to get good candidates if
they know this is possible knowing full
well
that there may be a merger here it just
seems to me that that
we this needs to be resolved before
any finalization of the selection
process
for the respective chancellors take
place i it's just
i think that what we could do is we
could also perhaps have
uh we could ask to have somebody from
the university system come in that might
have some answers to
uh because they're in the process of
looking for
chancellor right now so so is the
community college system
but i as i'm sure oliver here having
been
in this capacity before would want to
know what's the structure
what are going to be my obligations
responsibilities and duties here
and that could certainly change
drastically with the
with a new organizational framework um
i can tell you right now rick you don't
want a
a system in which there's no one in
charge
and all the presidents report to the
legislature
or somebody some other dealing with
their own deal it just turns into a dog
fight well that's not what we have
exactly right now but we do not have
a strong chancellor ceo system
yes we saw what happened in in case of
keene state when they were
down with uh with their revenues and
and needed some help over there and todd
went over and basically
lived at keene state trying to help them
climb out
which melinda did a great job in doing
that
um so but the chancellor has to be
your boss it has to be the the one in
which the presidents
are underneath the chancellor in my
perspective
but i don't believe that's the way the
structure is set up right now
they're oliver is that is that your
point
that's pretty much my point i can
remember when we got into competition
one of our branches got into competition
with a community college
who was giving a bachelor's degree in
plumbing
and so that got sorted out by the
by the chancellor well you also you also
have
you not only have the the coursework
stuff but one of the concerns i've had
is that
what's the coordination of of the
uh the building process of the the
capital improvement issues
i mean how do you determine within
particular institutions well
you can put that building here and you
can put that building there but we
wait a second we already have that
building over here so i mean
that we haven't even talked about the
capital improvement issues yet
and the fact is you have campuses that
you if you were starting from scratch
you might not create but they already
exist
exactly right now and so what do you do
with them
yeah and if you say the word closed in
anyone's hearing
you just it all just dissolves into
chaos
yeah that's right it's all there's a lot
of ownership
oh yeah rick i have i have a question
for you or oliver or anybody on the call
i've gone through we're going through
sort of the studies in the various
states and
raising questions and some some plans
are here and some are there do we
have any states that you're aware of
that have successfully merged those
systems
that we can now say whatever
nebraska did a great job let's look at
that and see what
how they did it does anything come to
mind for picking out a state or states
like that
i i can't honestly tell you that because
this is not really my bailiwick but
uh i i i got to assume
that yes restructuring is occurring
throughout this country right now
simply because of dollar availability
shrinking demographic
increased competition for those limited
pool of
of students uh and we see that in
our small region of new england really
see it
look what happened to the law school
here at unh
they're under attack from law schools in
the boston area for the same
student our population at the law school
was
half of what it was several years ago
and with that
you have problems maintaining your
professors and your
your instructors um you just don't have
the revenue so you have to borrow from
elsewhere within your university system
to maintain that school that can't
and that that but that goes back to the
question i had earlier
regarding the consolidation of certain
programs
um do we have we have we looked at that
and is that something that
needs to be looked at i don't know
because because the community colleges
frankly
have done that i mean they have
diversified
their programs to meet their respective
needs of their
their region so you know you don't have
a
you don't have a a big engine program
uh down in nhti you've got that up in
the berlin area i mean so
they have i think they've done a pretty
good job of trying to diversify
their programs to meet the the
demographics of their particular
regional area
so i i think that when we when we meet
with don burks
uh next week on wednesday don was
as i mentioned before in the
pennsylvania system yeah and when i went
out there
and and uh met with the folks in erie
pennsylvania last summer
where my grandson was thinking of going
to school
that school he was at the strength of
that school was their
engineering program in plastics and
molding
and um that what they drew a lot of kids
from
university park to go up to erie uh
and that and of course that's within
that uh
penn state higher education system which
is underneath the commonwealth system
uh it's it's a system that seems to be
working and growing and that
is one that they had to go through and
retool that back in the 80s
so don might be able to help us out with
that type of question that art asked
are there any systems that have gone
through this i know
maine right now is looking at trying to
restructure
their four-year schools in terms of
credits and accreditation
and that's what barbara brittenham is
going to speak to
on on friday up next
and barbara's also familiar with some of
those other retoolings going on
elsewhere in new england and so is susan
heward in terms of what happened in
connecticut
and that's in the report right here that
we have in front of us
i thought it was interesting that ed
kind of i think he not only implied but
stated that
he didn't think that from a cost savings
stands point
that he didn't think that there would be
much cost savings
in the merging of it i mean there may be
some from a
from a policy standpoint from an
institutional standpoint there may be
some merits to bringing people to
bringing together but i don't think he i
don't think he was saying that
don't think that there's going to be any
cost savings going on here so
i thought that was an interest
interesting comment he mentioned that in
in that that uh email he sent us that
attachment he mentions the fire program
yeah and uh that's something we may want
to get some more information on
in terms of where are where are these
synergies right now and
and and um unfortunately we just don't
have the time here
we may be able to get somebody to come
in if we're looking at
um next friday we have barbara
brittenham maybe we can park somebody
else in
there and maybe do the same thing and
make a larger conference type thing
either on wednesday too
with um uh um
with uh don and with susan how and maybe
we could get
you know catherine provencher's also one
that's
as a previous treasurer of our state
and and now the interim chancellor maybe
uh uh it'd be wise to ask and i spoke
with catherine last night
and she's open to working with us she's
she's very good
she's ready so maybe what i'll do is on
on the day that we're
next wednesday uh i'll i'll call up
catherine
and find out if there's somebody there
can help us a little bit with some of
this financial information
now remember also that right now there
is a briefing
going on with the division two right
yeah
and then they're going to have a
briefing on monday regarding the unique
program
yeah i think we need to realize that
we're not going to do the study
that's what that's exactly right i i
understand that all we all we can do is
is kind of say
here are some issues that need to be
looked at before we
go down this road and i think well
we can also do that identify this
quote laundry list of of issues but
recommend these
issues to our higher education committee
that
we have right right statutory authority
for
um and for a resolution also send it off
to division two and say here's
you know some policy issues from the
policy committee
need answers yeah okay good
you know i'm not taking one side or the
other on this whole thing right now i'm
pretty neutral on it
um i just feel like i'm out in left
field still i'm not even maybe in the
you're still trying to buy the ticket to
get in that's exactly
right oliver you got your hand up
yes i just wanted to ask you if you
could contribute anything about the
alaska
experience which seems to have been
something that took an
awful lot of tinkering with to get it to
work
well what happened up in alaska that the
governor of state don hammond um
we we had we had some issues and also
the geography of alaska you have
southeast alaska which is down
on that arm which goes down towards
washington
seattle area and then you have the rest
of state which is just
gigantic you could place alaska right on
top of the lower 48.
we also had in the latter part of the
80s the time when the oil glut was
occurred in the country
and alaska is a singular economy based
upon
oil the fishing industry is basically
dead
and when oil revenues went down a barrel
of oil went down and sank
well well below 50 bucks a barrel the
revenues coming into the state
which supported education took a
drastic cut so all of a sudden there is
fewer dollars available for uaf
university alaska fairbanks which is
their flagship campus much like our unh
and uaa university alaska
anchorage which is uh situated right in
anchorage and draws
a lot of folks from that where half the
folks in alaska live
and then yeah at that time you had the
university of southeast alaska and now
that's called university of southern
alaska i guess or
something such as that they've remolded
that but that system
had to change the demographics the
community college
also had to change community colleges
were only
used to be when i was there just a
singular building in a remote community
and it was oriented at the skill
certificates and skill training
that uh and not even at the level
of the the certificate that we're
talking about here in
in new hampshire we're talking about
subsistence type oriented cultures
and and and and and uh trying to provide
another route towards uh daily life
through education uh so it
it was it was it's a successful program
but it's very tailored
very tailored to the remoteness of
alaska
we through unh do research with uaf
um poker flats is where they put those
missiles up to study the aurora borealis
um our folks down in in durham are are
part of that program
so so we do work cooperatively with uaf
um so i i would i would
in that report i'd be really curious to
learn a little bit more about the
connecticut model than what happened in
minnesota
um in states which are have more in
common with
okay all right okay hey guys thanks a
lot rick
yeah so everybody can you hear me
yes i can mike yeah real quick uh
hello uh i've been on for a little bit
as you know i was at the uh
county meeting i saw mel there and i saw
dave
uh so anyway real quick jennifer had
sent me a message asking for the ecs
material that i
had received from ecs yeah if they can
get to her but
rick were you able did you get that from
me or were you able to was
did anybody else yeah we got it yes
i mentioned that mike i mentioned that
ecs material along with the
sheets we got from the community college
system are really informative
i i did mention that you had asked that
question
to provide us examples of post-secondary
mergers elsewhere in the country
and on the bottom of page one it had i
i'm looking at it right now as we're
speaking
uh objectives of system mergers may
include but the following and listed
five
real critical points uh i think those
five critical points
are points that we should be all looking
at the first one
is improved coordination and alignment
across the institutions
uh coordination and alignment that's
important
the second part is achieve cost savings
and efficiencies
ed mckay talked about efficiencies and
cost savings
but we should continue to hammer on that
one as well
number three expand access to credential
and degree programs
and academic courses we we we
talked about certification programs at
the community college the different
types of programs offered
and the fourth one is streamline credit
transfers we spent some
good time on transfers between various
levels of education here and the fifth
one was
increase the flexibility of institutions
to respond to changes
in student and workforce domain demands
that is where the community college is
really nimble
right now working with regional business
the the unh is looking for those bigger
institution corporations and they
also are are working with those large
corporations
uh however a small business is really
attached to community colleges
so those five areas mentioned in your
ecs
materials you got are really key for us
to follow those broad elements
with further questions and i've been
going through the
paperwork that jennifer put together
that you sent out there's a lot there
and i have some notes and
once i get jennifer's notes and i see
what you touched on today i'll
i'll try to get caught up as you know i
did i did spend 20 years in the
community system in in seven years in
the university system
plus five years as an undergrad as a i
guess i was in the five year plan so
anyway i have some some uh personal
history in both systems
that hopefully will be a little bit
useful so i'll try to get caught up in
and uh
sorry i missed a lot of what was here
today but i will try to get caught up
that's okay mike uh when you're also
looking at the reports look at the
consolidation of post-secondary systems
that report which was
i don't know how you say the term
nechams the national center for higher
education management systems was
requested
to do a report for the community college
system on page 27
of that report there's ten questions
those ten questions are good questions
for us to keep up on our heads so when
we meet with don burks next week
and with susan heward uh we try to you
know
ask those questions and try to you know
you know get information back we're not
going to be able to make any resolutions
or determinations but we can at least
get these policy statements and facts
down
so we share it uh with the division two
also mike i don't know if you heard our
last part of the discussion
where we're talking about an rsa rsa 187
which speaks specifically to the public
higher education study committee
we have a legislative committee tasked
with the responsibilities
for looking at the organization and
structure
of our post-secondary education systems
it's already there
it's already in statute so what we
should be doing as a result of this
subcommittee work
is taking some of the findings and facts
that we in questions
which we have noting it and sending
written comment
to that committee as well as well as
division two
yeah and sure for the study on their
part
okay great okay boys okay yeah good
have a good weekend yeah everybody enjoy
enjoy the summer weather
stay off stay off zoom for at least a
couple days i'm gonna try to and i hope
everybody else does the same
and i won't call that thing an elk a
deer anymore i know it's an elk oliver
okay everybody
the bear heads on the other wall thank
you
bye-bye